[Musique]
bien nous sommes au Centre de Musique de
Versailles aux compagnie de Margot
Lallier bonjour vous êtes la directrice
d'action pôle culturelle du Centre de
Musique Baroque de Versailles un mot
d'abord sur ce lieu où nous sommes
absolument merci beaucoup nous sommes
ici à l'hôtel des menus plaisir l'hôtel
des Menus Plaisirs c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal pour résumer
j'aime bien dire que c'était un petit
peu la boîte de prod de Louis XIV on
gérait ici
l'ordinaire et l'extraordinaire les
cérémonies les vont stocker les décors
c'était un lieu de un lieu de stockage
également ça a été ensuite un bâtiment
d'État où on a hébergé des
administrations divers et variées les
armées l'éducation nationale et puis
c'est en 1987 que le Centre de Musique
Baroque de Versailles prend ses
quartiers ici à l'hôtel des menus
plaisir ce qui le fait revenir quelque
part un peu vers son objet d'origine
absolument on va parler tout à l'heure
peut-être bon parler tout de suite
d'ailleurs de la création de ce centre
de musique baroque c'est à deux
personnalités Philippe beau sang qui est
critique de de musique et puis un
compositeur qui est Vincent Berthier de
Liancourt qui était aussi un organiste
absolument
87 c'est l'époque où on commence à
redécouvrir la musique baroque
absolument en fait à partir des années
80 on va commencer à se reposer la
question de cette musique qui était
considérée comme un peu ringarde en fait
cette musique baroque et puis ça vient
d'abord des artistes effectivement qui
vont redécouvrir cette musique et puis
la la remettre au goût du jour et c'est
ainsi que le ministère de la Culture
propose sur l'impulsion effectivement de
de Vincent Bertille Liancourt la
création de ce centre de musique baroque
de Versailles dont l'objet est de faire
rayonner la musique des 17e et 18e
siècle en France oui c'est ça la musique
baroque c'est la musique qu'on jouait au
17e et du 18e siècle et c'est assez
fascinant parce que il y a eu des
découverts des redécouvertes au 20e
siècle Vivaldi par exemple qu'on avait
totalement oublié et et évidemment
que vous faites ici au Centre de Musique
Baroque de Versailles c'est aussi
redécouvrir des partitions je suppose
absolument ça fait partie de l'activité
des chercheurs en collaboration avec des
d'autres personnalités dans le monde
entier qui redécouvrent régulièrement
des partitions oubliées ou peu connues
c'est le cas par exemple cette année sur
la musique du Régent donc le la période
entre
avant voilà
qui s'appelle je crois la Jérusalem
délivrée
très bientôt
en Belgique voilà c'est ça exactement en
Belgique puis en France on a des
redécouverts grâce à une collaboration
avec un musicologue américain des
cantats écrites par Philippe d'Orléans
et qui seront déchiffrés d'ici quelques
semaines ici au Centre de Musique
Baroque de Versailles une musique qu'on
avait complètement oublié
que la Régence après la mort de de Louis
XIV il a aussi écrit de la musique et
des opéras on va reparler des activités
qui sont très très nombreuses notamment
pendant le Mois Molière du Centre de
musique baroque mais je crois qu'il y a
un atelier que je voudrais bien voir qui
s'appelle les bébés baroques on va y
aller doucement on va aller voir les
c'est des bébés de 0 à 3 ans on va aller
les voir et puis après nous en
reparlerai ça marche ok on y va
[Musique]
alors Margot l'Allier on vient de voir
là c'est bébé 03 20 03 4 mois
avec avec une une intervenotte
formidable absolument d'où est venu
cette idée
l'idée elle vient surtout du fait que
cette hôtel des menus plaisir finalement
il est assez peu connu des Versaillais
aussi en raison du fait que puisqu'on
abrite une école on en reparlera mais
avec des enfants qui chantent le plan
Vigipirate nous oblige à fermer les
portes voilà et donc c'est aussi simple
que ça les portes sont fermées on ne
peut plus venir ici de façon aussi libre
que c'était le cas par le passé et donc
on s'est posé la question de comment
rendre à nouveau ce lieu accessible aux
habitants de Versailles et des Yvelines
et puis en fait il y a un vrai manque
d'activité pour les bébés alors on
connaît bien les bébés nageurs un petit
peu moins et bébés lecteurs mais les
bébés baroques ça te s'était pas encore
vraiment fait et puis on a rencontré des
artistes avec qui on a eu ces
discussions de qu'est-ce qu'on peut
proposer préparer pour les pour les
tout-petits et leurs parents les mamans
et les papas évidemment
où tout membre de la famille d'ailleurs
et c'est comme ça qui est arrivé cette
idée avec un horaire adapté puisque
c'est à dire le matin
mercredi par mois à 10h et puis de temps
en temps aussi le samedi matin avec deux
artistes chanteuses qui vont être plus
voilà sur du de la comptine de la
berceuse etc et donc voilà c'est une
activité qui remporte comme on a pu le
voir à l'instant un grand succès et puis
on essaye on va essayer sur la saison
prochaine de de continuer d'augmenter un
peu la proposition oui parce que les
parents sont évidemment conquis et les
enfants aussi il y avait une mère qui
disait danser des petites et c'est vrai
que l'animatrice est formidable aussi il
y a d'autres animatrices alors qui sont
des chanteuses absolument en fait l'idée
l'idée c'est de proposer des activités
pour les tout-petits dans une certaine
liberté de motricité aussi c'est à dire
que vous l'avez vu ils sont sur des
tapis des coussins ils ont le droit de
se lever de crier de chanter de danser
ils ont tous les droits absolument on
termine toujours les ateliers par une
petite découverte des instruments le
classeur le piano l'orgue voilà ça m'a
surpris parce que souvent
c'est un des instruments qui sont rares
qui valentchaient un clavecin il est
magnifique il y a un orgue il y a un
piano de hiceux et ben les enfants ils
vont ils tapent dessus et comme ils
veulent et personne ne leur dit rien
alors évidemment on jette un oeil
attentif sur sur
l'idée c'est de leur de montrer que
cette musique
baroque ou pas d'ailleurs en finalement
c'est c'est l'objet qui nous réunit ici
mais mais en tout cas à cet âge-là que
dans la limite évidemment de la sécurité
de chacun rien n'est interdit et qu'au
contraire mettre les doigts sur le
clavecin ça peut être une bonne une
bonne expérience et puis on verra
peut-être que dans quelques années bah
voilà ça se trouve des futurs musiciens
et des spécialistes de la musique
baroque alors il y a beaucoup
d'activités du centre pendant le Mois
Molière vous êtes très très associé au
Mois Molière qui est évidemment un mot
très important à Versailles avec
activités très différentes il y a des
Colocs très très pour les spécialistes
par exemple sur l'opéra de cours
avec qui fait je crois avec l'Université
de Lyon 2 enfin là c'est vraiment pour
les spécialistes et les universitaires
mais il y a aussi des journées portes
ouvertes des concerts
le Mois Molière c'est un moment très
particulier de l'année pour nous parce
que justement c'est l'occasion d'ouvrir
les portes alors on propose un cycle de
conférence pour le tout public tous les
mardis à 18h ici au Centre de Musique
Baroque de Versailles on propose
également des concerts de restitution de
du cœur de jeunes de la maîtrise le
dernier jeudi musical de l'année aussi
au début du mois de juin qui était qui
était proposé dans la dans le cadre de
la programmation du Mois Molière et puis
on propose aussi le 17 et le 24 des
journées complètes d'ouverture ici à
l'hôtel des menu plaisir soit pour des
actes
sont ouvertes là les portes sont
ouvertes on fait en sorte que ce soit
possible et on propose des visites
guidées des jeux de pistes des ateliers
d'écoute pour découvrir la musique
baroque et puis donc le 24 juin je vous
en parlais
une journée autour du clavecin et de la
flûte traversière ouverte à tous
familiale avec des démonstrations des
expositions et des concerts c'est ça qui
est formidable c'est que à la fois je
disais il y a des des Colocs pour les
spécialistes et qui sont très de très
très haut niveau et puis il y a en effet
c'est portes ouvertes où on peut venir
peut-être essayer la flûte traversière
parce que tout le monde commercial mais
mais voilà après il y a des très très
bons spécialistes donc c'est un peu ça
le au fond la mission l'une des missions
de ce centre c'est au fond le très haut
niveau et puis l'ouverture à tous
absolument en fait faire rayonner la
musique baroque des 17e et 18e siècle
c'est la raison d'être c'est l'objectif
que ces données le Centre de Musique
Baroque de Versailles tous les moyens
sont bons pour y arriver et que ce soit
avec des publics amateurs ou
professionnels des mélomanes des
étudiants on a aussi tout un pôle de
formation voilà donc l'idée c'est que
ici on n'est pas vraiment un musée mais
on est un lieu patrimonial on n'est pas
vraiment une salle de spectacle mais on
est producteur de musique et donc voilà
c'est un centre de recherche avec une
maison d'édition un pôle de chercheurs
une bibliothèque d'études qui est
également ouverte au public
intéressant il y a en effet une
bibliothèque je crois qu'il y a plus de
je sais plus combien d'ouvrages c'est
absolument formidable là n'importe qui
peut venir absolument la bibliothèque
d'études est ouverte au public alors
évidemment je vous le cache pas le
public qui vient ici sont plutôt des
étudiants des spécialistes et des
chercheurs mais dans l'absolu oui c'est
une bibliothèque d'études publiques donc
vous mettez les ressources ce qu'on
appelle les ressources à la disposition
du public il y a vous avez dit la
recherche on en a parlé les spectacles
on en a parlé et il y a la formation
tout à fait le Centre de Musique Baroque
de Versailles abrite une école
maîtrisienne c'est à dire des enfants
qui sont en classe à horaires aménagé à
l'école vapler et l'école et le collège
Rameau et qui viennent à temps à
mi-temps quasiment je dirais
apprendre le chant la musique ici au
Centre de musique banque c'est une
maîtrise laïque donc absolument public
et à religieuse mais qui se produit tous
les jeudis pendant la période scolaire
donc hors vacances scolaires à la
chapelle royale du château de Versailles
à 17h30 le jeudi il y aura alors c'est
de le dernier concert malheureusement
est passé mais la saison reprendra en
octobre novembre prochain absolument
parce que oui on disait il y a beaucoup
de choses pendant le Mois Molière mais
ça continue aussi au mois de juillet ça
continue aussi au mois d'août il y a
d'autres activités et puis on le disait
par exemple avec avec l'opéra de la
Jérusalem délivrée
vous avez des actions ici à Versailles
évidemment mais vous êtes aussi à Paris
vous êtes aussi dans le monde entier
dans le monde entier on a beaucoup le
Centre de musique baroque a beaucoup de
partenariats internationaux puisque
cette musique baroque française c'est
une spécificité qui ne s'apprend qu'ici
et donc on va aller proposer de des
partenariats avec je sais pas la Hongrie
le Brésil la récemment nos collègues
étaient à Boston pour accompagner en
fait des productions à l'étranger pour
travailler cette musique et la faire
rayonner voilà si vous voulez deviez
dire à des gens qui disent qu'est-ce que
c'est la buzule baroque euh
je suis pas assez parce que c'est pas
assez la musique pour m'intéresser à ça
pour les convaincreurs de venir
qu'est-ce que vous leur diriez alors le
mot baroque déjà ça vient du portugais
barroco qui veut dire perle irrégulière
et donc pour ceux qui aiment
disons les les beaux objets
larchitecture un peu
voilà avec plein de d'irrégularité de
voilà c'est
voilà exactement de détails voilà c'est
c'est une musique qui s'écoute écouter
ma foi très bien
auquel on s'habitue bien et
surtout ici au Centre de musique baroque
il y a des entrées pour tout le monde
pour tous les âges et tous les moments
de la vie on l'a vu ce matin on a des
actions ici à Versailles mais aussi en
or les murs et donc je crois pouvoir
dire qu'il y aura de toute façon une
entrée pour chacun ici et puis venir à
l'hôtel des menus plaisir c'est quand
même un truc formidable absolument et
donc toutes les 15 premiers jours de
juillet et les 15 derniers jours d'août
on aura des visites guidées en français
et en anglais assuré par les médiateurs
et médiatrices du Centre de Musique
Baroque de Versailles en fin
d'après-midi tous les horaires sont
disponibles sur le site internet
n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre et un
dernier mot pour parce qu'il faut le
signaler quand même il y a des
publications il y a des il y a des CD il
y a des DVD qui sont en vente ici
absolument vous avez sur la boutique du
site internet du Centre de musique
baroque tous les disques les DVD et les
ouvrages de littérature qui sortent
autour des redécouvertes de cette
musique baroque française et puis vous
avez également sur Spotify appel musique
cobles et toutes les plateformes de
streaming des playlists qui sortent tous
les mois et qui vous permettent à la
maison de rentrer dans cet univers
baroque et de de trouver une première
accroche voilà merci beaucoup Margot
l'avion on a pris un peu chaud mais ça
va le coup merci beaucoup à bientôt
[Musique]